Si os pregunto por una potencia emergente,
estoy completamente seguro de cuál sería
vuestra primera respuesta: la República Popular
China.
Ahora bien, según como la formulemos la pregunta
tiene matices….
¿Potencia exactamente en qué?
Si hablamos de potencia industrial y exportadora,
no hay dudas;
¿Potencia demográfica?
Obviamente;
¿Potencia económica?
Nada despreciable.
Pero… ¿Y potencia militar?
Pues queridos amigos, amigas, es esta última
cuestión la que va a acaparar hoy toda nuestra
atención.
¿Cómo está siendo la evolución militar
del gigante asiático?
¿Podemos hablar ya de una incipiente globalización
armada de China?
¿Cómo rankea en relación a Estados Unidos?
Fijaos por ejemplo en este gráfico.
El presupuesto militar base de Estados Unidos
fue de 778.000 millones de dólares en 2020,
mientras que el gasto de China apenas superó
los 250.000 millones.
Es decir, que hoy por hoy el Tío Sam más
que triplica el esfuerzo en gasto militar
del país de los tres reinos.
Claro que, tampoco resulta extraño, el presupuesto
militar de Estados Unidos es tan grande que
supera a los de China, India, Rusia, Reino
Unido, Arabia Saudi, Alemania, Francia, Japón,
Corea del Sur, Italia y Australia… ¡juntos!
Es el presupuesto militar de toda una fuerza
global.
Así, que con los números en la mano y teniendo
en cuenta la enorme diferencia que aun los
separa parece difícil que China termine alcanzando
a Estados Unidos en materia de presupuesto
militar durante la próxima década…
Ahora bien… Un momento, ¿Realmente le hace
falta para poder rivalizar con el gigante
norteamericano?
Atentos.
Durante los últimos 30 años China ha cambiado
mucho, y la cuestión es que su forma de entender
el ejército, la defensa nacional y sobre
todo la política exterior también han experimentado
toda una revolución que podemos dividir en
3 tres fases muy diferentes entre si:
(La primera fase correspondió a la estrategia
de la defensa mediante la guerra prolongada
a gran escala de Mao Zedong.
Su base esencial era disponer de un ejército
enorme, gigantesco aunque fuera rudimentario
y estuviera mal equipado.
Llegado el caso este plan preveía, incluso,
movilizar a los propios ciudadanos cuando
fuera necesario, aunque no contaran con entrenamiento
ni equipamiento específico.
Luego la segunda fase fue la conocida como
“estrategia de los 24 caracteres''.
Fue impulsada por Deng Xiaoping y pasaba por
mantener un perfil exterior y militar bajo
para favorecer el desarrollo económico y
no ser visto por el resto del mundo como una
amenaza.
Esta estrategia se mantuvo intacta durante
la presidencia de Jiang Zemin, aunque empezó
a cambiar durante la era de Hu Jintao cuando
dio comienzo la gran modernización militar.
Por último, la tercera fase corresponde a
la idea del regreso del reino del centro.
Una estrategia impulsada por Xi Jinping mediante
el llamado rejuvenecimiento nacional, y que
implica colocar de nuevo a China como eje
vertebrador de la vida política de Asia.
Para ello el dictador chino ha ordenado expresamente
convertir al Ejército Popular de Liberación
en una fuerza militar de primer orden para
2049.)
Y, ojo, porque la idea de Xi Jinping no solo
pasa por tener un ejército de primer nivel
que sirva para defender a China, sino utilizarlo
también para expandir su área de influencia
política.
Y amigos no penséis ni por un instante que
todo esto no es más que mera retórica o
meras divagaciones.
Los discursos y sobre todo las acciones del
líder chino no dejan lugar a la duda.
("Mientras ponemos un esfuerzo consciente
en aprender de la historia para crear un futuro
brillante, debemos acelerar la modernización
de la Defensa nacional.
Un país fuerte debe tener un Ejército fuerte.
[...] En una lucha heroica y tenaz, el PCCh
y el pueblo chino declaran solemnemente al
mundo que la nación china da la bienvenida
al advenimiento de un gran salto - del ascenso
a la prosperidad modesta y la fuerza naciente.
[...] La nación china ha entrado en un proceso
histórico irreversible".
- Xi Jinping, Presidente de la R.P.China)
Toda una declaración de intenciones.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo se ha llegado hasta aquí?
Y la pregunta del millón: ¿Tuvieron acaso
las políticas de apertura y desarrollo de
China el objetivo claro y determinado de convertir
al país de nuevo en la potencia hegemónica
del continente asiático?
¿O es algo que se está produciendo por la
propia evolución de los acontecimientos?
Sea como sea, el caso es que fue el Presidente
Hu Jintao, el antecesor de Xi Jinping que
gobernó China entre los años 2003 y 2013
quien empezó a romper con la visión no intervencionista
de Deng Xiaoping.
Fijaos.
(“Debemos conceder gran importancia a la
seguridad marítima, espacial y ciberespacial.
Debemos hacer una planificación activa para
el uso de fuerzas militares en tiempos de
paz, expandir e intensificar la preparación
militar y mejorar la capacidad para realizar
muchos tipos de tareas militares, la más
importante de las cuales es ganar la guerra
local en la era de la información.”
- Hu Jintao, ex-Presidente de la R.P.China)
Sí, lo habéis escuchado bien.
Al contrario de lo que muchos piensan, fue
Hu y no Xi quien arrancó la escalada militar
china.
Aunque claro, el actual líder ha llevado
las cosas mucho más lejos.
Solo tenemos que pensar en Hong Kong o en
las constantes provocaciones a Taiwán.
Casi que se podría decir que la diferencia
entre Hu Jintao y Xi Jinping es la que hay
entre serlo y creérselo: Hu quería serlo,
y Xi quiere creérselo.
(Hu Jintao puso en marcha una fuerte y rápida
modernización del Ejército Popular de Liberación.
Por ejemplo, durante su presidencia se cuadruplicó
el presupuesto militar en términos absolutos,
se superó por primera vez la barrera de los
150.000 millones anuales de gasto en defensa,
y en sus tres últimos años de gobierno Jintao
aumentó el presupuesto militar a un ritmo
de entre el 13 y el 18 por ciento interanual.
Gracias a esto, en la ‘era Jintao’ China
comenzó a operar su primer portaaviones,
lanzó las dos primeras versiones de bombarderos
furtivos y desarrolló toda una nueva gama
de misiles balísticos.
Uno de ellos, por cierto, de carácter intercontinental,
con hasta 14.000 kilómetros de rango el Dong
Feng 41 es capaz de alcanzar la mayor parte
del planeta.
Durante los últimos años de Hu Jintao se
sentaron las bases para que luego Xi Jinping
empezase a imponer en Asia, especialmente
en Taiwán y en el Mar de la China Meridional,
una superioridad militar más activa: es decir,
los chinos ya no solo tienen las armas, ahora
también las pasean para demostrarle a sus
vecinos quién tiene el poder.)
Es decir, que lo que hizo Xi Jinping fue heredar
y profundizar una carrera armamentística
que ya había comenzado, pero con un objetivo
más rimbombante: reconstruir la grandeza
de China, especialmente de puertas para afuera.
Claro que para lograr este objetivo, Xi no
solo necesita un ejército más moderno, necesita
sobre todo estar como mínimo a la altura
de Estados Unidos en Asia.
Y la pregunta, amigos, es… ¿Qué parte
de este ambicioso objetivo se ha logrado?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(¿EL REGRESO DEL REINO DEL CENTRO?)
Aunque parezca mentira, sí, ya hay cosas
en las que el ejército chino del 2021 ha
adelantado al mismísimo ejército de los
Estados Unidos, el ejército más poderoso
de toda la historia de la humanidad.
Concretamente podemos hablar de tres campos.
(En primer lugar, China tiene mayor capacidad
de construcción naval, lo que ha hecho que
la Armada de este país se convierta ya en
la más grande del planeta.
Tecnológicamente y en términos de tonelaje
aún está muy lejos de Estados Unidos, pero
su evolución y su creciente capacidad la
convierten ya en un enemigo difícil de batir
en un conflicto regional.
En segundo lugar están los misiles balísticos
y de crucero con base en tierra.
El ejército chino tiene ya más de 1.250
misiles balísticos listos para ser usados
en un conflicto regional.
Y por último, China cuenta con el mejor sistema
de defensa aérea del mundo.
Gracias a los sistemas rusos S-300 y S-400
funcionaban junto a otros sistemas autóctonos
los cielos de China son quizás los más fortificados
del mundo.)
Claro que de momento, y esto es muy pero que
muy importante, hablamos de capacidades regionales.
Me explico, muchas veces en los medios de
comunicación nos encontramos con noticias
y reportajes que nos describen a China en
términos de competencia directa con Estados
Unidos en el terreno militar.
Pero no es estrictamente cierto.
Los líderes chinos son conscientes de que
hoy por hoy las distancias siguen siendo siderales.
Por ejemplo, mientras que China solo tiene
dos portaaviones activos y un tercero en proceso
de ser completado para 2023, Estados Unidos
tiene 20 portaaviones en servicio.
Precisamente por eso el objetivo inmediato
de China no pasa por convertirse en una superpotencia
mundial sino sobre todo en una superpotencia
regional.
Es decir dominar el nuevo corazón económico
del mundo.
Y, amigos, ¿sabéis qué?
Ahí si las cosas están mucho más igualadas
y muy pronto China podría superar las capacidades
de Estados Unidos.
Y muy importante para lograrlo necesita mucho
menos recursos que el hegemón norteamericano.
Pensadlo un momento.
Mientras que Estados Unidos tiene un inmenso
océano de por medio, y por tanto necesita
una gran flota de portaaviones, equipos de
despliegue y bases militares repartidas por
todo el mundo, la situación del gigante asiático
es totalmente diferente.
(Al gobierno chino le basta con tener unas
fuerzas armadas modernas capaces de hacer
frente a lo que Estados Unidos tiene desplegado
en sus bases de Asia-Pacífico.
Una región dónde la potencia norteamericana
tiene desplegados unos 325.000 soldados, 180
buques, alrededor del 60% de toda la armada
estadounidense y unos 1.500 aviones.
Pues bien, para lograr su objetivo, a China
le basta con superar las capacidades norteamericanas
en la región.
Y eso es exactamente lo que están persiguiendo:
limitarse a su vecindario más próximo.
En el resto del mundo, en cambio, China sigue
una estrategia de influencia alejada completamente
de la esfera militar: se dedican a invertir,
comprar empresas, dar préstamos a países
en vías de desarrollo y construir infraestructuras.
Una estrategia que quizás le puede dar muchos
frutos durante las próximas décadas pero
que hoy por hoy no tiene ambición militar
alguna.)
Claro que no hace falta.
El mundo ha cambiado y hoy controlar Asia-Pacífico
basta para condicionar toda la política mundial.
Y eso, eso es precisamente lo que explica
que a la hora de la verdad la diferencia de
presupuesto militar entre Estados Unidos y
China puede no ser tan importante.
Además, los chinos cuentan en cierto modo
con otra ventaja: la etérea frontera entre
la economía civil y el campo militar.
(Desde la llegada al poder de Xi, se incorporaron
requisitos militares a la infraestructura
civil, y se aprovechó la construcción civil
para fines militares.
También se han aprovechado capacidades logísticas
y de servicios civiles para reforzar la capacidad
de las fuerzas armadas, al tiempo que se ha
profundizado y expandido el sistema de movilización
de defensa nacional que tiene como objetivo
contar con todos los recursos nacionales para
su uso en la carrera militar china y, eventualmente,
en una guerra.
Todo esto que os estamos contando tiene nombre
y apellidos: La Estrategia de Desarrollo de
Fusión Militar-Civil, también conocida como
MCF por sus siglas en inglés.)
La base industrial de defensa china no estuvo
tan fusionada con la tecnología civil e industrial
desde la época de Mao Zedong.
¿Y qué quiere decir todo esto?
Pues básicamente el gobierno chino quiere
aplicar al campo militar toda la evolución
tecnológica y operativa de las empresas chinas.
Es decir, en otras palabras: el gobierno chino
quiere convertir al país en todo un fortín
y en una fuerza imbatible en Asia-pacífico.
Para lograrlo Xi Jinping está dispuesto a
utilizar todos los recursos que sean necesarios.
Y eso, eso también significa que en cierto
modo el presupuesto militar puede no estar
reflejando todo el esfuerzo que China está
haciendo en el terreno militar.
¿Queréis un ejemplo?
Pues ahí está por ejemplo el conocido como
collar de perlas chino, un proyecto que consiste
en el desarrollo de bases, puertos y estructuras
navales bajo control de empresas chinas desde
el mar de las China Oriental hasta el mismísimo
Mar Mediterraneo.
En principio la red tiene un enfoque civil,
pero no nos engañemos es probable que muchos
de sus nodos tengan también un uso potencialmente
militar.
Desde luego los analistas militares es algo
que dan por hecho.
Es decir, en otras palabras, que la carrera
entre Estados Unidos y China, la carrera de
verdad, la carrera que importa puede estar
mucho más igualada de lo que podríamos pensar
en un principio.
Sí, la superioridad económica, tecnológica
y militar de Estados Unidos sobre China sigue
siendo enorme, pero a pesar de ello ya no
está claro que la potencia norteamericana
podría superar fácilmente a China en Asia-Pacífico,
el nuevo corazón económico e industrial
del mundo.
Está es la globalización armada con la que
sueña el gigante asiático.
Controlar la joya de la corona para influir
en todo el mundo.
Ahí es, amigos, dónde Xi Jinping parece
estar saliéndose con la suya y es exactamente
ahí dónde se sitúa la nueva prioridad de
los Estados Unidos de América.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Cómo crees que Estados Unidos y en general
los países occidentales pueden contener el
creciente liderazgo de China en la región
más importante del mundo?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus respuestas.
Y ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.